The answer should be 5 rows. We'll always have the first one, and then each
additional row is another 400 times root 3 meters of length. So, to get the
total number, we can do 4000 minus 800 over how much we need for another
additional row. So, 400 root 3, and then we add 1 because there's that first
row that took up 800. This calculation would give us 5.61. But we said that we
couldn't have fractional rows. So, we just get 5. Let's generalize what we just
did, if you already know the equation for the number of rows given the length
of the field, write it down and skip to the next question. Based on what we did
up here, the equation should be, rows equals the length, minus the diameter
over the radius times the square root of 3 plus 1. Remember the radius was the
400 and diameter would be 2 radius' or 800. And then once we do this
calculation, we would drop the decimal. Save this, you're going to need it
later.